das was für mich zählt ist dass wir uns
zum schluss zusammengerauft haben und
dass wir jetzt auch alle davon überzeugt
sind aus dem was wir beschlossen haben
wirklich etwas machen die europäische
union einigt sich endlich auf ein
historisches millionen paket das größte
hilfspaket aller zeigten insgesamt 18
millionen euro werden zur verfügung
gestellt davon sind 1074 milliarden für
den nächsten siebenjährigen
haushaltsrahmen vorgesehen und 750
milliarden für ein konjunktur und
investitionsprogramm gegen die folgen
der pandemie krise wir haben damit die
weichen für die finanziellen grundlagen
der europäischen union für die nächsten
sieben jahre gestellt und gleichzeitig
eine antwort auf die größte krise seit
bestehen der europäischen union gegeben
die zuschüsse sind etwas weniger mit 390
milliarden die garantien etwas mehr
geworden mit dem finanzpaket will sich
die eu gemeinsam gegen den
wirtschaftseinbruch stämmen und den
eu-binnenmarkt zusammenhalten
gleichzeitig soll in den umbau in eine
digitale hre und klimafreundlichere
wirtschaft investiert werden
europa hat immer noch den mut und die
fantasie groß zu denken und so erschöpft
wir jetzt auch alle sind hier wir sind
uns bewusst dass dies ein historischer
moment in europa ist auch der
französische präsident emanuel micron
twitterte bereits ein historischer tag
für europa das ist ein guter deal einen
starken und vor allem ist dies der
richtige deal für europa jetzt um kurz
nach mitternacht gab es noch einen
zweiten durchbruch die 27 staats und
regierungschefs haben sich auf eine
formel geeinigt wie die auszahlung von
eu geldern künftig an die einhaltung von
rechtsstaatlichkeit gekoppelt werden
soll
die gelder werden also gebremst wenn
gemeinsame werte missachtet werden das
war zuvor eines der größten streitthemen
damit liegen zwei wichtige bausteine für
die lösung des finanzstreits vor